after one week of allegations of
disgusting behavior from an echo fox
shareholder enough is enough hate has no
place in eSports
[Music]
so let's start from the beginning
last month the Saros Richard Lewis
reported that Rick Fox was trying to
leave the eSports team he founded echo
Fox due to alleged racist behavior and
threats made against his family by
another than unnamed shareholder Nick
stared OHS reporting continued over the
following days revealing that the
shareholder in question was a man named
Dmitri Zeta now Rice Otto released a
statement in which he admitted to
lobbing racial epithets at former echo
Fox CEO Jace Hall but he also said that
he never threatened riff Fox's family if
the emails that Nick Soto published are
real than the things that rides on a
said to Jace Hall are pretty terrible
but then the Kyodo published emails
allegedly sent by rosada in which he
clearly threatens Rick Fox's family so
that was a [ __ ] lie now it actually
gets worse from here a new site called
up comer published texts in which rosada
allegedly sent anti-semitic insults to a
former business partner Rick Fox
responded by telling TMZ that he's
willing to stay with echo Fox if the
organization removes rights odd though
he also said that unfortunately it's not
as easy as it sounds he has rights as
well being the unfortunate thing is
being a racist in America or being a
racist in general is not illegal
unfortunately and so he has his own
economic interest in his own rights so
no one no one's gonna trample on his
rights but I have my rights as well now
that brings us to today where literally
as a recording this riot has made a
statement about the whole echo fox
situation riot says that the LCS has
concluded its preliminary investigation
into the alleged comments made by a
member of the echo fox ownership group
hate speech threats and bigotry have no
place in the LCS we have directed echo
fox to take appropriate corrective
action within 60 days if echo fox does
not take action by removing any
individuals whose actions violate league
rules and agreements within the required
time period the league will take formal
action that may adversely impact the
future of echo fox in the LCS in english
echo fox news to get rid of rosada or
riot will take action against them oh
now you [ __ ] up nay [ __ ] up now you
[ __ ] up you have [ __ ] up now okay
now that we have all the facts of this
issue lined up we all can relate to this
at least on some small level because
when we play any game whether it's
League of Legends
RCS or anything there is always some
kind of talks of behavior in chat and
that's kind of what's happening to Rick
here the difference is that when someone
is toxic in a game you have a lot of
ways of dealing with them you can mute
them you can dodge you can just shut
down your client stop playing for 20
minutes and come back the problem is
that Rick Fox doesn't have any of those
options he is stuck in a business
relationship with an allegedly toxic
person now if somebody in your ranked
games was saying the kind of stuff that
rise oughtta allegedly said riot would
ban them which is actually what they're
trying to do now what can riot do in
this situation they don't really say
exactly what their formal action will be
but I can take a couple guesses I don't
know what riot can or can't do but I'm
willing to assume that right can't just
kick a team out of the LCS given their
franchising agreements instead I assume
that riot can probably sanction them
somehow maybe make trades harder find
them remove their bans before every pro
game something like that things that'll
make it more difficult for echo fox to
succeed and thus gain sponsors so that
puts us in a situation where there are
three potential futures the first is
that things continue as they are right
now echo fox doesn't do anything within
60 days and riot is forced to take
action now nobody wins in this situation
riot doesn't win because they don't want
to take action against one of their
teams it just it looks bad for the
league it's bad for their branding it's
just it's not healthy for the LCS echo
fox doesn't win because whatever actions
Wright takes against them will make it
more difficult for them to win and be a
profitable company eSports as a whole
doesn't win because one we lose Rick Fox
who's been a great face for eSports they
are digital athletes they're
professional athletes and two were left
with somebody who's allegedly said some
pretty terrible stuff the second
possible future is a pretty good one in
this future Bryce autist steps down echo
Fox is in the LCS without any actions
taken against them and Rick Fox stays on
with the team basically everybody wins
here but rosada who again is allegedly a
jerk so I don't really mind that one
vacillation the third potential future
here is a little bit speculative but
stick with me in this potential future
the echo fox shareholders including
rosada sell echo fox off before the
60-day deadline now this would be
difficult but it would put us in an
interesting situation it will be a win
for Riot because that individual who
violate
rules and be out of the system it will
be a win for East force because hate has
no place in eSports and getting rid of
the alleged source of that hate can only
be a good thing the problem is that it's
also a win for rosada who's gonna walk
away from this whole thing with a chunk
of change now he wouldn't be an esports
anymore so I guess he's not a problem
now that Wright has spoken up it's clear
to see that they don't want hate in
these sports and based on the response
I've seen on social media Twitter and
reddit you guys don't want hate in these
sports either I haven't had many
personal interactions with Rick Fox he's
always been really cordial to me and is
a great interview but it doesn't matter
who this kind of behavior is directed to
Ward's any kind of racist behavior
eSports shouldn't stand Rick Fox has
been really good for eSports over the
last couple of years he was one of the
first big names to come in with outside
money and invest in eSports he shows up
to all his games he's just a really
incredible face for eSports and losing
him for any reason sucks
fellow team owners have spoken up in
support fans don't want to see Rick Fox
leave and that's the kind of thing that
gives me hope for eSports that we won't
stand for racist behavior in our scene I
don't know if it's true or not but if
that's true like there isn't any place
in eSports for racism or anti-semitism
or threats against people's family there
isn't any place in it for any kind of
terrible behavior at all so what can we
do well honestly I think we should do
what I've already seen people do on
social media people on Twitter and
reddit have already been speaking up
against behavior like this and in
defense of Rick Fox so now it's up to
the echo Fox shareholders and hopefully
we can convince them that pate has no
place in eSports or at the very least at
the alleged source of this eight will
finally step down thanks for watching if
you want more content like this hit the
sub button and ring that notification
bell for unique bite-sized videos you
won't find anywhere else
hit up art Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]